you oh he's so right i love this
thank you for all the work thank you
guys you're right
you hurt thank you
i could cry
[Music]
what is happening there reject nation we
are back at it again we're continuing
the tradition
of you rock stars loki episode five they
are claiming
every easter egg found and this was one
of those episodes when we were doing a
reaction of i'm not even gonna really
try
there's you could just tell from the
shot when they first
go to the void planet oh god there's i
bet there's like because
he strikes me pause and scrub yeah
watch blind waves reaction i'm like how
the heck do you catch so much when
you're reacting
that is so crazy anyway i'm very much
excited for this can't wait to see
because you know this is an easter egg
galore episode here we go welcome back
to new rockstars i'm eric boss and this
is a breakdown of loki episode 5
journey into mystery of course a nod to
the original comic run that introduced
loki and thor
fitting for an episode filled with
easter eggs to marvel comics
but also enough hatches egyptian icons
and smoke monsters to haunt me from the
series that got me into this kind of
stuff
lost which hopefully loki will do better
than with expectation management
all right he's already got a great point
because there's only one more episode
left i'm like there's so much i gotta
wrap up i know you got a season two
coming but still feel like for your
complete story of season one there's a
lot you gotta
wrap up already we gotta meet the wizard
hey let's break down this episode frame
by frame for all the interesting hidden
details because this episode's got a lot
of them hey and a reminder that you can
get our lucky inspired merch at
newrockstarsmerch.com
like this loki out of time shirt which
directly supports it
i love it we open on the tv timeline
screen with your mission showing vormir
the planet that held the soul stone
infinity war in in-game
seoul south korea zimbabwe and oak
island nova scotia maybe a nod of the
oak island treasure
the theorized knights templar treasure
believed to be buried on oak island
might contain the holy
upside down and then rotates as the
chrono monitor room
back wall just dissolves into the time
keeper elevator doors
which then dissolve into their chamber
where we now reverse the rotation so the
frame rotates counter-clockwise
toward the seventh timekeeper android
head a true journey in the mystery this
opening shot is
reflecting how each of these settings
have been in their own ways smokescreens
for some deeper truth beyond them
much like how the final shot of this
episode is yet another literal smoke
screen
healing back to reveal some other truth
beyond but even that might contain
another secret twist yeah i have sauron
series keep focusing on that one central
time keeper more than the other two
almost as if that android could be a
primary one specifically designed in its
creator's image
we enter the void the tva's supposed
dumping ground
we passed the lighthouse of alexandria
one of the seven wonders of the ancient
world now this void also contains the
pyramids of giza
another ancient wonder and with the
hanging gardens of babylon showing up in
eternals that makes three out of seven
wonders in the mcu this year
this lighthouse also bookends the lit
tower which maybe is the lighthouse in
the final shot and trailer footage tells
us that that setting has a library
inside it
perhaps another source of illumination
next on the left is doctor strange's
sanctum sanctorum i would not want to
look at the
from it maybe there reactions some past
conflict between the sorcerer supreme
and the tva over who really should
i got nipple chills from that man it is
not avengers or any or stark but
king as in king enterprises the company
tony stark
sold this tower to in the comics it's
run by mr gryffin
revealed to me kang the conqueror the
latest clue that kang
could be our man behind the curtain
after all damn it
there's more and more and more clues i'm
at a crossroads here because
originally i've been very sold on king
conker recently i'm like no it's kind of
probably king look for all the reasons
we said in our reaction that i won't
reiterate here now i'm like
ah i really don't know what it's gonna
be now i really don't know what it's
gonna be i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna stick
to king loki
i'm gonna say that these kang uh
illusions are all very intentional
because i mean he's right around the
corner yeah so like he's gonna be here
and even if these are long
play easter eggs the real maybe king
loki or whoever
we're gonna really see somehow under the
thumb of king the conqueror
i don't know we'll see i'm just oh god
already there's so many to the left is
another building if you look closely at
the top of it is labeled
ken park 2018 it looks like suggesting
this whole void could be made up of
pieces of histories that
kang has conquered similar to his
kingdom of chronopolis
2018 would be right after the snap which
could be when
kang enterprises moved into that tower
notice how trotting around on the ledges
are these indigo bird things with their
spherical heads that hover over their
necks they run on five little hot dog
feet all over the void
no clue what these are but this episode
was written by rick and morty writer tom
kaufman
who wrote the season three froopy land
clone death episode with a similarly
bonker's pocket reality filled with
goofy creatures and an immature exile
who crowns himself king
and then finally some answers what is
this place who are you
this is the void that's a lion and wear
his lunch come on
goliath is a trans-temporal entity from
the marvel comics who takes the form of
this kind of carnivorous smoke
he rivals the time empire of kang the
conqueror
goliath in eternal battle so that kang
can expand his rule
and it just so happens that ravana
renslayer is also part of this 1993
storyline so i'm wondering if in this
case
kang may be using goliath as a guard dog
as he works behind him to assemble his
kingdom
rensselaer explains workloads in
branched reality it's impossible to
destroy
basically the branch timeline isn't
reset it's transferred to uh
a void at the end of time yeah rinse
layer is appealing to the law of
conservation of mass that says matter
can neither be destroyed nor created
only transferred not that the laws of
physics
really matter that much on the show but
rensselaer claims to not know who
created the tva
and based on her later scene with b15
she truly could be a memory wiped
variant
same as the rest of them but this being
rinsed layer the primary love interest
in the comics too kang
i wonder if she could be a teacher or an
admin from that
fdr high school that caught the eye of a
young nathaniel richards
maybe even a teacher that he had a crush
on and once he grew up to be kang
he went back in time to trap her in this
phony temporal law office so that she
would catch the bullies and class clowns
who threaten his utopia that would be
such a messed up abusive
relationship but maybe she's also
toxically drawn to it that's why
she's still like no we need to keep the
tva in order even though i don't fully
understand like a victim
yeah she can't sleep and she's like so
attached to this cycle of toxicity that
somehow she just like knows how to
operate within it and drives a weird
sort of power from it but more
importantly i
love the idea of kane the conqueror
being a high school student at franklin
d
roses high school having a crush so bad
on a teacher that it creates a time
organization around you back in the void
is a three-masted wooden
ship with light boats on the deck this
could be the santa maria
columbus's flagship that struck a reef
off the coast of present-day hades sunk
and its wreckage was never recovered
they passed this huge flying saucer
another aerial phenomenon that could
have just been spotted on earth and then
pruned and then they passed what looks
like
red skull's spinning rocket from the
first captain america film which was
based on the real life
german folk wolf tribe of hugo fighter
plane built during the later years of
world war ii
and then this row of giant bald head
statues partially buried in the ground
kind of looks like the big head
sculpture in
canmore in alberta canada the home
province of that son of a [ __ ]
james aka logan aka wolverine who do you
think i was gonna say go [ __ ] yourself
so these loki variants are classic loki
richard e grant dressed in loki's
classic attire from the early comics
boastful loki whose clothes look like
the dark rain era of loki
he wields a mjolnir made from a piston
and a piece of a train rail kid loki who
carries loki's levatin
sword from norse mythology and alligator
loki and loki asks them
but have you thought of using a temper
oh the one thing that could easily get
us out of here yes
they're all over the place right guys
[Laughter]
fine ah loki gator blinks as gators do
side by side but it plays like an eye
roll here what i really love about the
fact that his millionaire is made out of
that
is because he has a later speech where
he's like i beat
thor and i took the infinity stones you
know just adding to the fraud persona
that boastful loki really is placed
hubris
yes and they pass a big pile of lunch
trays which must be ones from the tva
cafeteria like rather than cleaning and
reusing them they just prune them all
early
spider-man's heist all the high schools
are also boxes of boku fruit juice it's
definitely for the tvs but his next
event was
i killed the bull yikes perhaps kid
loki's thor
died when that trick that thor mentioned
in ragnarok led him to bleed out this
one time with real children he
he transformed himself into a snake and
he knows that i love snakes so i went to
pick up the snake to admire it
and he transformed back into himself and
he was like yeah it's me and he stopped
me
we were eight at the time then there is
a giant helmet of the ant-man villain
yellow jacket
scene with his damage resizer nothing
but perhaps
still alive somewhere in the quantum
realm this recalls the shocking imagery
of ant-man's giant corpse strewn across
the post-apocalyptic landscape and old
man logan
and then yes thanos copter one of the
goofiest toy pushing moments from marvel
comics with endgame lightly referencing
it when thanos rotated the sword
now presumably pruned from some
alternate timeline though this could
mean some alternate timeline thanos was
pruned here and then maybe consumed by
goliath there's also a huge
warhead maybe some stolen nuke that were
it not pruned would have started
a global nuclear war and then they
entered this hatch that we get a better
look of later with text written on it in
hindi in the circle that translates to a
and then the yellow writing on the right
proves dwarf entry door
and then to the green on the left
sabdahan viscella
careful poisonous so maybe this is a
hatch for an indian nuclear facility or
their nuclear submarine the ins
arihant or could it have been like yeah
when there's like a nuclear war
you know like blast from the past
christopher walken puts his whole family
down underneath yeah they just have like
a fallout shelter that's what it's
like prepared for any situation and they
just happened to get one that was
manufactured in india
mm-hmm there you go c c easter egg salt
added nothing means
nothing then a great floorboard gag
sinking down to show us what is buried
underneath more lunch trays and
silverware
a buried mjolnir and trying to get to it
a thor
frog in a jar marked 365 a nod to throg
in thor comic issue 365. i love how you
can hear him grunting as he throws
himself against the glass just like how
thor did in his cell in the first
avengers
their hideout is a customized bowling
alley looks like circus lanes written on
the back wall there
kid loki has made a throne out of what
looks like a santa land from a mall
or did santa get pruned too there's a
space mission pinball game
and then a polybius arcade box this was
an urban legend from the portland area
in the 80s and 90s that claimed the
government could have rigged
games called polybius for hypnosis and
mind control uses
rentslayer and missed minutes work
together to try to stall sylvie
find loki find the man behind the
curtain and kill him yes the man behind
the curtain of course a direct nod to
the wizard of oz which this tva mystery
creator is
clearly based on i would love it if king
the conqueror really is just that just
like the old guy
talk to bakers yeah
way miss minutes picks up these
non-verbal cues from rentslayer is just
another reason to think something more
will be revealed about this character
but back in the bowling alley they
listened to the mike flowers pops cover
of wonderwall
an intentionally hokey cover of that
annoyingly sincere song by oasis that
like that one
[ __ ] at the party in college who
brought his guitar has to play
they drink roxy wine ro xx probably got
it from
roxcart classic loki and boastful loki
both have huge chalices but they gave
loki a small one
kid loki sips hi-c ecto cooler between
them
is a book the mystery and lore of
monsters by cjs thompson a rare 1930
survey
of human deformities and monster lore
alligator loki calls
[ __ ] on boastful loki's tale of
defeating cap and iron man getting all
the infinity stones
well at least my nexus event wasn't
eating the wrong neighbor's cat
alligator loki goes right for his hand
just like how he later
looks president loki and classic loki
explains how he survived thanos
i cast a projection of myself so real
even the mad titan believed it then
hid as inanimate debris this is crazy
the writers apparently
worked into classic loki's backstory a
fan theory that channels like ours
discussed back in 2018 that during
loki's death scene in infinity war a
floating
piece of debris in the background looked
like loki with his big
curved horns making us think that loki
might have faked his death at the time a
theory that i was forced to apologize
for
i just look forward to the 2024 ghost
rider movie where mephisto says agatha's
devils in the details come back was a
reference to him classic loki says he
oh wait wait what if what if
that loki did survive and that's who's
running the
no that's stupid
well that would be a perfect place to
hide the clue though because he's got
shown that in his memory reel of like
see you're supposed to die this way
maybe that's part of the secret thanks
for trying to encourage me
but yeah i mean i remember we were
watching like this isn't that a fan
theory that was going around yeah
that's what he did and i think it's
really cool just how out of all the
shows
uh so far from like the marvel disney
plus stuff they seem to be the most
tuned in to when it comes to easter eggs
yeah
this is just a prime example more than
just a production design thing it's
actually in the text of the screenplay
that they did that that's nuts
classic loki says he landed on a remote
planet and stay there in isolation
in solitude for a long
long time yeah he says he got lonely and
tried to leave and then he got arrested
i wonder if his lonely planet could have
been vormir
referenced earlier this episode but also
back in episode 2 where the screen
listed a nexus event on vormir in the
year 2301 which would have been hundreds
of years after that moment with thanos
but i do have another theory on this guy
just more on him later they meet a new
loki gang led by president loki who's a
reference to the 2016 boat loki
miniseries in which loki runs for
president pledging that he's not afraid
to lie to people but then there's this
other bearded one who was the same one
who was labeled variant l 8914 back in
episode two
another one has a helmet made of
silverware probably gotten from all
those tva lunch trays and then another
with a helmet with a bike handlebar
sylvie who pruned herself earlier
awakens on a school bus and enchants a
branch of goliath getting a quick vision
of what it's guarding the rock ring
suspended at the end of time that i
pointed out in trailer footage with a
castle and a lit
tower now this castle does look a bit
like a darker version of neuschwanstein
in germany which is an inspiration to
many fantasy castles mobius street
to save her notice how the plate number
is jira in w-1d
so maybe like growled maybe a nod to
mark gruenwald's the marvel comics
writer
of many of these influencing titles that
in the comments what the dea staff was
all designed to look like
specifically
behind them is a suspension bridge that
looks like a cross between the towers of
san francisco's two major bridges
both golden gate bridge and oakland bay
bridge wasn't there an x-men fight on
that bridge
yeah right x-men three yeah there's a
big old showdown on the bridge
that's got to be a nod to that right
yeah the best exposure
looks like ratner's x-men all right
i know it's not or it could be ant-man
related also san francisco
chongqi also san francisco it could be
big hero six
it could be uh the movie milk based off
harvey books
it could be bullet with steve mcqueen
and oakland that's where we left off of
black panther
exactly every ryan coogler movie is up
there
and then there's also a sign for
wrightville theater screening the movie
oswald and the martian now a different
similar town wrightsville pennsylvania
showed up in a nexus event in 1832 but
this movie might be referring to
mars a 1930 short animated by walt
disney for universal starring oswald the
rabbit mobius drives past the pyramids
of giza and the sphinx but notice the
sphinx has not
lost its nose perhaps that's why it was
pruned because it was supposed to lose
it and yes a reminder that the pyramids
of the sphinx do show up as trophies in
kang's chronopolis if that ends up being
the case but to the right is a structure
that before i thought was stonehenge but
in this clear footage i don't think it's
stonehenge it has these greek columns to
it so i don't know maybe some ancient
greek structure
maybe the white house after it was
burned down in 1812. i don't know i've
been going on the historical kick while
i'm watching the show the loki's all
bigger you led the wolves to our door
we prefer snakes to wolves i read some
both they
die just the same snakes in the woods
the great snake and van rear the wolf or
fenris and the mcu both of whom are
loki's offspring in norse mythology yeah
i thought it was actually linked to
how that line that they played earlier
in this video of like he transferred
something to this [ __ ] thor loves
snakes so i thought his family loves
snakes yeah and they fight with fenris
and uh you know ragnarok
it's your your thing's an easter egg too
your thing is an easter egg also you're
so much cooler man picture of this like
really imposing sinister snake we gotta
read more norse mythology
alligator loki bites off president
loki's hand causing him to let out a
very long scream if you listen to it all
the way through
[Music]
classic loki gets them out of there by
conjuring up duplicates of themselves
with duplicate kid loki tossing
alligator loki and one of the others
also known as thor and loki's get help
maneuver get help
help him
nice the uss eldridge
this was a real-life world war ii era
ship that was believed to be part of a
debunked conspiracy theory known as the
philadelphia experiment in which people
claimed
it was given an invisibility shield
vanished the teams regrouped
at a barber shop where they roast one of
those bird creature things and
interestingly
mobius didn't remember there ever being
an alligator loki
perhaps another clue that there just
could be multiple mobiuses meanwhile
loki and sylvia chat outside
it's cold frost giants aren't supposed
to get
cold so loki must have been conjuring up
that blanket just so they could snuggle
smooth that's a great point it is a good
point
i think one thing that i i wish this
show kind of honed in on a little bit
more
is the fact that he is a frost giant
i'll be honest i forget that i need to
be reminded of that from time to time
oh yeah it's constantly like oh yeah
that's right yeah i mean well that's
maybe season two this
could be loki going back home yeah i
don't really know what they need to do
story-wise to remind us that he's a
frost tribe
i mean they even show frost giant loki
in the first second episode and i forgot
one of the birds climbs this tank
this is the chrysler tv8 a
nuclear-powered tank that was designed
by chrysler in the 50s to be deployed
against the ussr but
thank god was never actually put into
production but maybe this happened
where this did actually happen probably
with horrible results
how did i not oh my god he's a hundred
percent right
yeah once you see the ship floating
you're like that's exactly it oh i
thought it was
like a big old ship or a wall yeah it
did not oh
right that's a thousand percent right
damn that's an easter egg i wish i
i caught i should have caught on that's
what i should have caught onto
you suck there also looks like an oil
platform maybe this is the deepwater
horizon so loki asks mobius
what will you do at the tva burn it to
the ground
thanks for the spark call back to loki's
promise all the way back in the first
episode i'm gonna burn this place to the
ground
now on this landscape you can see the
head of the living tribunal that's the
three-headed cosmic judge of all the
multiverse
i don't know what timeline its head
would have come from but i do like how
loki and silvi stand in front of it as
they face goliath
almost as if they are now on the side of
justice in this noble fight
and a little later in the scene there is
in the background a crashed helicarrier
this is the first time i have to keep
pausing to rewind okay so look at it
damn and the hydrology really you have
to like slow down
i mean that's a blink and you'll miss it
yeah i'm sure i'm sure some of you guys
caught it uh but damn i didn't i did not
catch that one especially the hydra logo
you gotta like up the brightness and
like really
look to find that you oh he's so right i
love this
thank you for all the work thank you
guys you're right
you hurt damn thank you
i could cry finale we'll cry
we'll cry the new rockstars breakdown
finale not during the actual finale
but we'll cried heard the british look
at all the hard work he's done
loki waves his flaming sword to try to
distract goliath but it does not work
making him remember what classic loki
said
earlier the blades are worthless in the
face of a loki's sorcery
they stunt uh magical potential so loki
realizes he must drop this sword
and join sylvie in her enchantment but
they get
some major backup from the old man
what a fantastic what a glorious moment
natalie holt's music is incredible
she actually said she used a 32 voice
choir for all the vocals here and you
might have noticed right in this moment
it's samples richard wagner's norse
inspired riot of the valley
he casts this epic illusion of asgard
which at first
looks a lot like the emerald city in the
green light there but i love
its detail down to those statues of
warriors past on all the edifices but
the illusion fades and classic loki gets
consumed
though notice how he did have some green
sorcery glowing in his hands but then
just lets it fade the final second
as he laughs with glee making me wonder
if this guy could have pulled an obi-wan
and
let himself get taken here so that he
could respawn in a new form hold that
thought i'm almost there
because sylvie and loki enchant alive
and open the gate
to beyond the void revealing the castle
with the lit
tower on the rock ring at the end of
time who will they find there
well yes this series has done a lot to
point to kang the conqueror because sure
why else would you include ravona
rinslayer and goliath
and kang enterprises and all these
chronopolis parallels just to completely
avoid the upcoming mcu big bad that
connects these dots but hey we've been
led astray before right so you could
make the case for other possible big
bads like doctor doom maybe an evilest
loki maybe some version of miss minutes
or simply what if we were to just follow
the theme of the man behind the curtain
a weasley old man the creator of the
timekeepers in the comics
he who remains and i will leave you with
this folks
notice as they approach that castle a
piece of debris floats up now at first i
thought this could have been a ship but
even if it is just debris classic loki
just confirmed that
can sometimes be a loki in disguise
after he fakes his death
classic loki for some reason passed up
mobius's offer to leave the void
and then he stayed and showed off an
insane level of sorcery
sorcery that he spent who knows how long
refining
and then could have faked his death in
that moment
who survived and built the timekeepers
and the tva
in order to control the multiverse with
this ultimate illusion
whether or not you believe that or if
you think it's kang or someone else
you gotta admit that truly would be a
classic loki move
that would be a bomb loki movement that
would be harassment and then we have
richard e
grant in the role as well yeah you know
richard e grant could pull off both what
we saw in episode
five and then do the big reveal but what
about the shot though with the
with the king loki that's not it well i
mean maybe that could be in a further
illusion maybe even
like if we want to go with this theory
maybe richard e grant could cast a
projection or some kind of illusion
of that loki or something i don't know
like part of me does think that maybe it
is a different
loki and maybe this is just his way of
getting in there but
i don't know it would be really really
fascinating if it was
just it's classic loki it lines up
very well with how so much of this is
referential the wizard of oz
absolutely yeah yeah yeah not to go too
too off the weeds but you know he is in
this like old school kind of classic
looking you know
and he is old and he's old you know it's
very wizard of ozzy already just with
his appearance if you slow it down it
looks like he's already like his cape is
turning into kind of like
particles before elias even starts to
comes towards him yeah maybe this is
just his secret entrance way to like get
him right where he needs to go he
doesn't have to travel and like do all
the like getting onto the space ring
he just goes right up to the tower
that's a crazy theory voss and i think
i think you're onto something comment
down below with your theories as we head
into this finale episode
and another reminder to support this
channel by checking out our merch
options at neurosciencemerch.com
follow me on instagram twitter at ea
boss follow and subscribe to new
rockstars i'll see you next week for the
finale thanks for watching bye
we'll be here thank you mr voss that is
thank you that was brilliant that truly
was easter eggs galore
these enhanced so much experience guys
subscribe to new freaking rockstars if
you haven't done so already you can
subscribe to us keep a lookout for our
reaction to finale and of course we'll
be checking out mr bosses as well
hit that like button leave your theories
down below
and hey let's do a
chris wham-off thought of you during
this episode because you know what loki
part of the journey is about this guy
becoming a better person
a more attuned and involved person in
the lives of the people around him and
if there's anybody at our patreon who
embodies that
and then some chris it's you you're one
of the most
charitable giving wonderful people
who follows it like i i almost feel like
your contribution
comes with an extra layer of love just
simply because of what a good
human being you are so i hope you're
doing well
keep on keeping on in the free world
doing good stuff and uh we'll catch you
next time much love buddy
hope you're good